if one wants to think of this movie as a
fairy tale feel free that's not really
exactly where I'm coming from on it I
kind of consider bastards uh the the
first part of my rewriting history
Trilogy I didn't start the movie with
the idea oh and this will be the movie
that I kill Hitler when I'm writing it's
about the page it's not about the movie
it's not about Cinema it's about the
literature of me putting my pen to paper
and and writing a good page now I've
invested in this world to such a degree
now now I am these people these
characters they are me the hope is by
the 40 Mark or the 50 Mark that the
characters just take it from me and then
from that point on they're writing the
story in the course of my story my
characters change the course of the war
that didn't happen because my characters
didn't exist they had existed everything
that happens is fairly plausible